make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and
yeah let's begin
all right what's going on guys this is
rob and we are back with the king
in black from marvel comics something
that i do want to clarify though i was
incorrect in the first king and black
video that i made that it was simply
just a one shot
the reading order i'd looked at before
uh did not show king and black parts two
through five so i thought it was simply
just a one shot opening comic and that
was basically it
um it turns out the king in black is an
actual main series right so it's issues
one through five uh king and black one
through five
and then a whole bunch of tie-ins for it
so i do wanna correct that um i was i
was incorrect about that a lot of you
guys pointed out in the comments so
thank you for that i would not have
known had you guys not mentioned
it but uh but this one kind of opens up
this is the the venom tie-in right this
one opens up
basically with eddie brock kind of
falling to his death at the end of the
first king of black story when null just
stripped him of a symbiote and then
dropped him but what this does is it
initially starts out with rex strickland
now rex strickland was the first of the
individuals out there to be bonded to
the grendel right so just kind of a
reminder of the timeline here
um if we if we go on the way things used
to be before donnie kate's venom run
all you had was a venom simian that
bonded to eddie brock over the years a
lot has been done to change things and
donnie cates has introduced a lot of
information that we didn't previously
have and what donnie cates introduced
was the character of null who
by this point you guys should know as
kind of the guy who created the
symbiotes but then also the grendel and
the grindel was kind of a step above
your regular symbiote right so you have
like the one that bonds to eddie brock
which makes him venom or like the
carnage symbiote that bonds to cletus
cassidy which makes him carnage so on
and so forth the grindel's kind of a
step above that
right so if there were a hierarchy here
he'd be between venom and
like null or something along those lines
and even within that you have your own
little hierarchy
insofar as like where the venom
symbiotes rank and we might create a
video like that right like ranking the
venom symbiotes from strongest to
weakest
but uh but the idea is that rex
strickland and his team
were basically bonded to what was the
grendel symbiote so they were a little
more powerful than venom normally is
there was a point where really in the
beginning of donnie kate's run when he
first started on venom where eddie was
contacted by rex strickland and then
sent on a mission now we ended up
learning
that rex had actually bonded or really
the simulated had kind of replaced rex
after rex had died so he's kind of a
walking talking symbiote but eddie was
set on a mission to basically save you
know those guys who were out there those
other symbiotes what we never really saw
was what was going on in the background
while eddie was doing that
involving rex and what rex really does
is he kind of talks about the nature of
eddie now
this is important because this kind of
monologue that rex strickland offers in
the form of a diary entry
kind of overlays everything that we see
going on in this
comic right and so one of the things
that he sort of hits at here is that
sending eddie on this mission
was almost as much of a test as it was
just the need for help
and the reason why the test aspect came
in is because with rex strickland and
his grendel he became aware of the
nature of null null's existence the
power he possessed and the fact that
null would return to earth one day and
so looking at that
it was kind of like okay if eddie can't
do something as simple as like face off
against these grendels and basically
stop them
uh then what what hope could he possibly
have against somebody
like null but as you saw with with rex
kind of talking about uh eddie brock and
and so on and so forth one of the things
that he talks about is flash thompson as
agent venom and the flash thompson is
agent venom was a far more effective
venom than eddie brock was now a lot of
that was because of the military
training and history that flash thompson
had
and the fact that he was basically a
government-sanctioned symbiote kind of
operating out there doing his own thing
but he was a lot more effective he
understood the necessity of nuance he
understood
uh getting in there and kind of
practicing espionage stealth tactics
different things like that he's not like
eddie
right eddie is a guy who just goes
running in guns blazing right even if he
doesn't need to
and even when he shouldn't it's all he
really knows right he's just kind of a
blunt object just attacking whatever's
in front of him that's why a lot of fans
really
liked flash thompson as agent venom more
than eddie brock
because you got to see somebody use the
venom symbiote in a way that you
normally never really see which is why i
say we should probably cover that story
if for no other reason than the fact
that it could really kind of permeate
and attach itself to this
story kind of book in and show us how
the other you know how the simulates can
be used
but at the end of the day uh rex kind of
he he hopes the best for eddie brock
but he's not 100 sure that eddie brock
can really even succeed
because looking at everything's going on
individuals possessed by the grendel
symbiote and all that kind of stuff the
return of north his fear is that eddie
will fail right eddie will fail to rise
to this occasion and in the end he'll
end up dying just like everybody else
and that's kind of the thing that we get
here because we transition to the moment
when
null drops eddie brock and with a
quickness eddie was taken over
exceedingly fast and that's one of the
big struggles that we're kind of left to
solve here with regards to the king and
black story because what you're talking
about is a being so astronomically
powerful he was able to overtake the
overtake the celestials
that's no small feat right being able to
run up on a celestial being these guys
create like you know life they create
you know stars and galaxies they're on
par with galactus in terms of power
and so being able to subjugate a
multitude of celestials
is not a small thing here so then you
have like eddie brock with a venom
symbiote and it's got it's kind of like
how could he possibly hope to stand
against null in the first place and
that's the first thing
that donnie kate showed us right now
ripped the simeon off of eddie brock
dropped eddie brock to his death and the
simeon actually begs and pleads right
it's like no like do not take me from
eddie he absolutely needs me this is
really one of the the best developments
that came
from the work of donnie cates and even
some of the people that came before him
with regards to the venom stories is it
gave the venom symbiote more humanity
instead of it just being this symbiote
that bonded to eddie brock and it was
pissed off the spider-man rejected it
they're just gonna get revenge by doing
bad things and then eventually he teams
up with spider-man to fight carnage
instead of something like that
the venom symbiote actually has a mind
of its own it has desires it has
ambitions it wants to stay
a good guy it doesn't want to be you
know kind of enveloped into the fold
of null and kind of taken to a place of
subservience it wants to keep being a
good guy alongside eddie and that's cool
that's a really really amazing concept
but ultimately the venom symbiote is
seemingly absorbed by null
back into his essence and then in turn
eddie's just kind of left
to fall to his death now this is
probably one of the most beautiful
moments of this story right and this is
why donnie kate's
smashes it when it comes to his his
handling of venom so here's the thing
this is what's so cool about this
stories like this these are the kind of
stories that we reference when we do
character explanation videos or
something like that
about how like a character is totally
reworked so like when we talked about
magneto for example we talked about how
like with uncanny x-men issue number 200
magneto totally changed and became a
good guy this is the equivalent of that
right it's it's a little long
a little more long form insofar as the
transition of eddie brock becoming a
good guy
it certainly you know happened a lot
longer than the transition of magneto
but the principle's still the same right
if
in 10 years we do a video kind of an
updated video
on venom explain we'll reference this
right and we'll say like once donnie
kate took over the title
he totally changed up eddie brock and
the venom symbiote and kind of revamped
them into a whole new form and so on and
so forth this is what we're talking
about here right so you guys are kind of
seeing this happen in real time but for
eddie brock himself he kind of looks at
this and
and literally starts to pray and that's
something that we don't really see of
eddie because eddie's not an overly
religious man and just kind of says look
like you know i i'm praying to whatever
god is up there listening
i'm not really worried about me i'm
probably just going to fall to my death
this will be the end but
but what i'm asking here is that you do
not that you basically keep an eye
on my kid right make sure my son is okay
that dylan does not deserve to inherit
my darkness
right this this kind of horrific
circumstance that i've been living in my
entire life this desire for revenge and
all this anger and wrath that i've been
filled with over the course of my life
right this thing that's dominated me
right this thing is controlled every
waking hour
you know everything that makes me who i
am do not let my son inherit it now one
thing that i do want to point out
pretty much everything from the time
that null drops eddie brock until we get
to the end of this comic
happens in the span of 32 seconds 32
seconds and that's all you get
and i love stories like that right where
like all these things happen in the in
the span of 32 seconds well eddie
brock's falling to his death these
symbiotes of null are
or they're just they're they're getting
to work right like they're attacking new
york uh the avengers are all being just
kind of taken over
by uh by the symbiotes right spider-man
is doing what he can captain america is
doing what he can
but they're literally fighting a living
army of beings that are almost kind of
like a walking talking liquid
it's it's very difficult to overcome
that especially when they're empowered
by a guy who's a multiversal force of
power right it's not a simple thing and
so as
eddie brock continues to fall he begins
to realize the entirety of new york is
basically lost right it's it's
essentially conquered now from there you
switch over to dylan right again this is
still in the span
of this 32 seconds you switch over to
dylan and dylan you know kind of has a
radio of sorts and manages to hijack her
or
somehow attach himself to the frequency
that iron man and all the avengers are
on and i'm asking like how in the world
did you possibly get this you know he's
like well i got it from some person
spider-man you know he gets pissed off
at spider-man because he thinks he's the
one that gave it to dylan
but but at the end of the day iron man's
like look you got to keep this radio
channel clear right like this is how the
avengers are talking to each other we
need to know what's going on we can't
have some kid you know hijacking the
airways wanting to know what happened to
his dad you know we've got it under
control we're doing the best we can here
if you've got a tv watch that instead
and then cuts off dylan and dylan starts
to get pissed off because when that
happens he literally tries to reach out
with his uh with his abilities to tap
into null
and kind of see what's happening but
then the actual venom symbiote itself
which is still part of knoll
actually pushes out dylan and says no
you cannot access this you cannot access
null if you access null he'll know where
you are right he'll figure out where
where it is that you're at
and he'll come for you right so no like
get out of the brain of null
and just forf forcefully ejects him and
the you know for for dylan's part when
he was talking to the symbiote he felt
fear
but he felt fear and absolute panic and
that's when he's kind of like you know
by instead of my connection with severed
what did they not like what didn't it
want me to see and that's when he looks
up at the tv and he sees
null ripping off the symbiote of eddie
brock now of course he's seeing this
after it's already happened but he's
seeing like the symbiote being ripped
off eddie and then eddie being thrown to
his death and so as
eddie continues to fall there's actually
a helicopter that's that's trying to
outrun one of these giant you know these
these grindels right one of these giant
uh you know symbiote bats
whatever you want to call them symbiote
dragons eddie kind of warns them like
you can't outfly this thing right like
you've got to just you literally have to
land somewhere and just run for your
life but by that point the dragon gets
ahold of the hold of the helicopter
helicopter basically ends up crashing
down
and then eddie kind of caught in the
explosion gets gets sent
flying now the funny thing about this is
that the very fact that he was sent
flying through here starts bouncing off
these you know the kind of walls and
things like that
it's probably broken every single bone
in his body or at least
most of them but he'll survive and the
reason why is because he goes crash
landing onto a car which is covered in
symbiote goo
but with that being said guys that's
where it ends
this massive cliffhanger uh if you guys
are new here to comments explained
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and i got to tell you guys
i am absolutely loving king and black it
was every bit worth the wait
it was every ounce worth the wait like
let me know what you guys think right
because i love it let me know what you
guys think about king and black do you
guys love it
is it just one of the coolest things but
uh yeah
i will catch you all later peace
[Music]
hey
[Music]
a place with a
[Music]
we can make it happen
[Music]
turn things around
let's be the change we want to see
[Music]
[Music]
is